esto es pemba mozambique donde familias
desplazadas esperan noticias de los
suyos y más de 3.300 desplazados han
sido registrados en pemba y sus
alrededores huyeron de la vecina ciudad
de palma por tierra mar y aire algunos
siguen desaparecidos decenas murieron en
el intento niñas y mujeres fueron
esclavizadas violadas y obligadas a
contraer matrimonio
el responsable estado islámico lo que ha
sucedido en palmas es un horror absoluto
infligido a la población civil por un
grupo armado no estatal eso es lo que
puedo decir han hecho cosas horribles
todavía lo están haciendo reflexiones de
astel twin show palmas es una ciudad al
noreste de mozambique situada en la
provincia de cabo delgado un entorno
rico en rubí oro grafito y gas
precisamente hace unas semanas la
empresa francesa total reanudó la
explotación de gas en la zona con una
inversión de más de 23.000 millones de
dólares tras enfrentamientos recientes
con el ejército el autodenominado estado
islámico consiguió tomar el control de
la ciudad antes en agosto de 2020 el
grupo terrorista había controlado mo
symbol
a un importante puerto marítimo con
salida al océano índico un contexto en
el que los jóvenes de la rica región se
sienten olvidados su local kóminik is
the feeling abandona las comunidades
locales se sienten abandonadas por los
esfuerzos de rescates que se centraban
en extranjeros y trabajadores del gas se
puede hacer que los extremistas
violentos reclute fácilmente a los
jóvenes porque se siguen desesperados y
abandonados cruch en cabo delgado acnur
registrados mil fallecidos y cerca de
700 mil desplazados desde 2017 cuando
nació al shabab la facción de estado
islámico